PLUS, HE EXPOSES WHY VAN JONES
IS FINALLY PRAISING THE
PRESIDENT.
STACEY ABRAMS CAME OUT EARLIER
TODAY.
AND WHILE SHE CLAIMED SHE
PROBABLY DOESN'T HAVE A VICTORY
IN THIS RACE, SHE'S STILL
FALLING SHORT OF MAKING A
CONCESSION TO BRIAN KEMP.
SHE SAID SHE'S FILE A FEDERAL
LAWSUIT FOR GROSS MISMANAGEMENT
OF THE PROCESS.
YOU DON'T LIKE HOW THE ELECTION
IS PLAYING OUT, SO YOU THREATEN
LEGAL ACTION AND CALL FOR AN
ENTIRE RE-ELECTION.
AFTER BROW-BEATING TRUMP OVER
WHETHER HE WOULD ACCEPT THE
RESULTS OF THE PRESIDENTIAL
ELECTION, THE DEMOCRATS HAVE
MADE THIS CONSTANT CHALLENGE
POSTURE THEIR NEW NORMAL.
NO ONE LIKES TO LOSE.
I DON'T.
BUT THIS IS ALL GETTING A LITTLE
BIT RIDICULOUS.
HERE WITH REACTION IS SOMEONE
WHO REPRESENTED THE GREAT STATE
OF GEORGIA AS SPEAKER OF THE
HOUSE, NEWT GINGRICH.
AND, NEWT, FIRST QUESTION, WOULD
THE ABRAMS CAMP FEEL THIS
EMBOLDENED IF DEMOCRATIC LEADERS
-- YOU'VE GOT HILLARY CLINTON
DOWN THERE, CORYBOOK, EGGING
THEM ON, BASICALLY SAYING IF SHE
DOESN'T WIN, THE ELECTION WAS
STOLEN.
>> LET'S START WITH THAT.
YOU HAVE A WHOLE SERIES OF
DEMOCRATS WHO JUST SAID BLUNTLY,
IF OUR CANDIDATE DOESN'T WIN,
THEY STOLE THE ELECTION.
THEY HAVE NO PROOF OF IT.
BUT THEY HAVE A WHOLE MODEL NOW,
WHETHER IT'S YELLING "RACIST" OR
WHATEVER IT IS, WHERE IF THEY
SMEAR YOU ENOUGH -- THIS IS THE
KAVANAUGH MODEL REPEATED OVER
AND OVER AGAIN.
SO GEORGIA -- THEY WANT TO SET
UP STACEY ABRAMS SO SHE'LL BE
THE PERSON WHO HAD THE ELECTION
STOLEN FROM HER.
SO FOR THE NEXT FOUR YEARS, SHE
CAN RUN FOR GOVERNOR AS THE
PERSON WHO SHOULD HAVE BEEN
GOVERNOR, EXCEPT IT WAS STOLEN
FROM HER.
OF COURSE, SINCE SHE'S BLACK,"
MUST HAVE BEEN AN ACT OF RACISM
AND THE WHOLE THING COMPOUNDS.
THIS IS A GAME THEY'RE PLAYING.
YOU LOOK AT FLORIDA WITH A
SIMILAR PROBLEM.
THE DEMOCRATS ACTUALLY WERE
METHODICALLY PLANNING TO CHEAT
ON THE ELECTION AFTER IT BECAME
SO CLOSE.
AND ACTUALLY WERE PRINTING UP
MATERIALS THAT WERE DESIGNED
JUST TO STEAL THE ELECTION.
THEY ONLY BACKED DOWN BECAUSE
THEY GOT CAUGHT.
BUT WE'RE SEEING IN BOTH FLORIDA
AND GEORGIA A VERY SIMILAR
PATTERN.
IF YOU DON'T LET THE DEMOCRAT
WINNING, THEY'RE YOU'RE
CHEATING.
AND IT'S STOLEN BECAUSE YOU'RE
NOT ALLOWED TO WIN.
THEY'RE SUPPOSED TO WIN.
>> Laura: WELL, NEWT, THE
GEORGIA CODE ON WHEN YOU CAN
CONTEST THE RESULTS OF AN
ELECTION IS VERY CLEAR.
SECTION 21-2522, AS THE RESULT
OF A PRIMARY ELECTION MAY BE
CONTESTED ON ONE OF THE
FOLLOWING GROUNDS, MISCONDUCT,
FRAUD, OR ANY IRREGULARITY
SUFFICIENT TO PLACE IN DOUBT THE
RESULT.
THERE'S NO EVIDENCE THAT ANY OF
THAT HAPPENED HERE.
IT'S ALMOST LIKE NONE OF THE
FACTS MATTER.
THIS IS ALL ABOUT 2020.
THIS IS ALL ABOUT BUILDING THE
MOMENTUM FOR MORE IDENTITY
POLITICS GOING INTO 2020 WITH
THE GOAL OF FINALLY FLIPPING
GEORGIA TO A TOTAL BLUE STATE.
THEY WANT TO DO THAT IN FLORIDA,
NEWT, THEY WANT TO DO IT IN
TEXAS, AND THEY'VE MADE SOME
GAINS IN TEXAS.
IN THE SUBURBS OF DALLAS, THEY
WON SESSION'S SEAT.
THIS IS A PLAY THEY'RE MAKING
AROUND THE COUNTRY IN THE
REDDEST OF STATES LIKE TEXAS.
>> SURE.
LET'S START WITH THE IDEA, WHY
WOULD WE THINK THEY WANT TO OBEY
THE LAW?
THEY DON'T THINK THE LAW
MATTERS.
THEY THINK THE LAW REPRESENTS
THE OLD ORDER.
ABRAMS SAID AT ONE POINT IN THE
CAMPAIGN, HER BLUE WAVE INCLUDES
LEGAL AND ILLEGAL PEOPLE.
SHE SAID, I DIDN'T REALLY MEAN
THAT.
BUT SHE DOES MEAN IT.
AGAIN OVER AND OVER, EVERYWHERE
YOU TURN, CALIFORNIA, WHICH HAD
A WEIRD SERIES OF VOTES,
ARIZONA.
THE FACT IS AGAIN AND AGAIN YOU
HAVE A DEMOCRATIC PARTY
DEDICATED TO WINS AT ANY COST,
DEDICATING TO STEAL THE ELECTION
IF THEY HAVE TO, AND IF THEY
CAN'T WIN, DEDICATED TO BLAMING
THE REPUBLICAN.
THIS WEIRD EXPERIENCE, THEY TRY
TO STEAL THE ELECTION.
IF THEY FAIL, THEY SAY, YOU'RE
STEALING IT BECAUSE YOU WON
HONESTLY.
AND SADLY, BECAUSE OF THE
LIBERAL NEWS MEDIA, THEY GET
AWAY WITH A LOT OF THIS.
>> Laura: WELL, NEWT, WE HAVE
OTHER VERY BIZARRE THINGS
HAPPENING.
AND I CAN'T BELIEVE WE'RE NOW
LOOKING AT 2020.
BUT A WOMAN THAT YOU HAVE PUT
OUT AS SOMEONE WHO MIGHT BE THE
NOMINEE IN 2020 IS KAMALA
HARRIS.
AND YESTERDAY I THINK SHE
SHOCKED EVEN DEMOCRATS WITH HOW
SHE DESCRIBED I.C.E.
LET'S FIRST PLAY NEWT'S
PREDICTION THE LAST TIME YOU
WERE ON ABOUT THE SENATOR WE'RE
SPEAKING ABOUT.
>> I PERSONALLY THINK IT'S GOING
TO BE KAMALA HARRIS.
I'M GOING TO STICK WITH THAT,
UNLESS SHE DOESN'T RUN.
I THINK AN AFRICAN-AMERICAN
WOMAN, FORMER ATTORNEY GENERAL
FROM CALIFORNIA, JUST HAS
ENORMOUS RESOURCES.
AND I THINK SHE CLEARS THE
FIELD.
>> Laura: LIKE I SAID, YOU
PREDICTED SHE WOULD BE THE 2020
NOMINEE.
ALLUDE TOGETHER WHAT I JUST
RESEARCHED, THIS IS WHAT SHE
SAID AND IMMIGRATIONS CUSTOM
ENFORCEMENT JUST YESTERDAY.
>> ARE YOU AWARE OF THE
PERCEPTION OF MANY ABOUT HOW THE
POWER AND THE DISCRETION AT
I.C.E. IS BEING USED TO ENFORCE
THE LAW?
AND DO YOU SEE ANY PARALLELS?
>> I DO NOT SEE ANY PARALLELS
BETWEEN SWORN OFFICERS AND
AGENTS.
>> I'M TALKING ABOUT PERCEPTION.
>> I DO NOT SEE A PARALLEL
BETWEEN WHAT IS CONSTITUTIONALLY
MANDATED AS IT RELATES IN
ENFORCING THE LAW.
>> ARE YOU AWARE THAT THERE'S A
PERCEPTION?
>> TO PUT I.C.E. IN THE SAME
CATEGORY AS THE KKK.
>> Laura: THE KKK, NEWT.
THAT'S WHERE WE ARE NOW WITH A
DULY APPOINTED AGENCY UNDER THE
UMBRELLA OF NATIONAL SECURITY.
THAT'S WHAT IT IS.
IT'S ALL ABOUT RACE.
>> IN A DEMOCRATIC PRIMARY,
WOULD YOU RATHER BE THE PERSON
CONDEMNING LAW ENFORCEMENT OR
THE PERSON DEFENDING LAW
ENFORCEMENT?
DO YOU WANT TO BE THE PERSON
WHO'S DEFENDING SANCTUARY CITY,
WHICH ARE AN EXPLICIT ACT OF
BREAKING THE LAW, OR DO YOU WANT
TO BE A PERSON WHO SAYS, MAYBE
WE SHOULDN'T BREAK THE LAW AND
SHOULD TURN IN ILLEGAL
CRIMINALS?
NOW, YOU KNOW IN A DEMOCRATIC
PRIMARY, IT IS A DEAD LOSER TO
BE PRO-I.C.E. AND TO BE
PRO-LOCKING UP CRIMINALS
>> Laura: I GET IT NOW.
>> IT SOUNDS WEIRD.
BUT I'M NOT SURE IT'S WEIRD FOR
THEM.
>> Laura: SO FOR THEM IT MAKES
PERFECT SENSE.
I WANT TO PLAY ONE MORE THING
FOR YOU.
THIS IS FROM YOUR FRIEND JOE,
FORMER REPUBLICAN, PANHANDLE
NATIVE.
WHAT HE SAID ABOUT WHAT'S
HAPPENING TO THE REPUBLICAN
PARTY AND THE FORMER STRONGHOLD,
FOR INSTANCE, OF ORANGE COUNTY
IN CALIFORNIA.
LET'S WATCH.
>> YOU LOOK AT ORANGE COUNTY.
MY GOSH, AS TOM SAID,
CONGRATULATIONS REPUBLICANS, YOU
JUST LOST REAGAN COUNTY.
IT LOOKS LIKE IT'S GOING TO BE A
COMPLETE WIPE OUT.
I REMEMBER WHEN SANCHEZ BEAT BOB
IN ORANGE COUNTY BACK IN THE 1
1990S.
IT WAS A STUNNER.
NOW IT IS A SEA OF BLUE, A HUGE,
HUGE CRUSHING DEFEAT FOR TRUMP
REPUBLICANISM.
>> Laura: IS THAT WHAT WAS
DEFEATED IN CALIFORNIA, TRUMP
REPUBLICANISM, NEWT?
A VERY FACILE ANALYSIS BY THE
TOWERING INTELLECTS AT MS NBC?
>> I THINK WE HAVE TO FACE THE
REALITY.
THE SIZE OF THE UNION-BASED
MACHINES ARE NOW SO ENORMOUS
THAT WE DON'T FRANKLY KNOW RIGHT
NOW HOW TO COMPETE WITH THEM.
I MEAN, THAT'S HOW BIG THIS
PROBLEM IS.
AND SO I THINK WE'VE GOT TO
CONFRONT THE REALITY THAT WE ARE
DEALING WITH A VERY PROFOUND
CHANGE.
WE JUST HAD A CANDIDATE FOR CITY
COUNCIL IN SEATTLE, AN
INDEPENDENT, WITHDRAW FROM THE
RACE BECAUSE HIS WIFE WAS BEING
THREATENED, HER JOB WAS BEING
THREATENED, HER SAFETY WAS BEING
THREATENED AND HE WROTE A VERY
POIGNANT MEMO SAYING HE WAS
FRIGHTENED TO EVEN RUN IN
SEATTLE BECAUSE THE FORCES OF
THE LEFT NOW ARE SO VICIOUS AND
HOSTILE.
AND WE HAVE A REAL PROBLEM IN
OUR LARGEST STATE, CALIFORNIA,
AND OUR FOURTH LARGEST STATE,
NEW YORK, IN THAT BOTH NOW ARE
CENTERS OF ENORMOUS UNION-BASED
POWER THAT IS SO BRUTAL AND HAS
SO MUCH MONEY THAT WE FRANKLY
RIGHT NOW DON'T KNOW HOW TO
COMPETE WITH THEM.
>> Laura: THERE'S MASS
IMMIGRATION THAT'S CHANGED
CALIFORNIA, NO DOUBT ABOUT IT.
AND IN MANY RACES, THERE'S NO
REPUBLICAN RUNNING AT ALL.
THEY'RE JUST BASICALLY TWO
DEMOCRATS RUNNING EACH OTHER.
THIS HAS BEEN HAPPENING OVER
YEARS.
THIS DIDN'T JUST START HAPPENING